[Musik]
en schweren unrohen in der beliebten
Urlaubsdestination
in hat der Präsident nach der
stürmungöchu sollen die Letten euürger
die sich noch im Lande aufhaltenell
wurde die Lage am Flughafen im gibt es
Befürchtungen dass sich auch noch
Österreicherinnen und Österreicher im
Krisengebiet
auf wir befinden uns hier in der
Vorbereitung
evakuierungsoperation weil Österreicher
aus einem unsicheren Drittland evakuiert
gehören ja alszinario ist ist eigentlich
das ähnliche wie in Afghanistan oder im
Sudan D wurden ebenfalls evakuieren
durchgeführt natürlich auch Imp
Zusammenarbeit mit anderen Nationen mein
Name ist bloder David Dienstgrad
stabsaumeister bin beim jägerbon 17 in
Straße in der Steiermark zugskommandant
der bolution S zurzeit das modernste
Gefechtsfahrzeug imim österreichischen
bundesher zeichnet sie aus durch den
hohen Minenschutz und durch die hohe
Mobilität im schwierigen Gelände medewak
ist die medizinische Evakuierung aus dem
Ausland beginnend von Verletzungen die
im Ausland nicht versorgt werden können
bis hin zur intensivmedizinischen
Betreuung durch unseren
intensivcontainer mit der hercolis mein
nahes haupmannarzt dr
marioasni ich bin seit 2017 in der
felner molland Hörsching ich bin
Facharzt für
Allgemeinchirurgie
im Vorhinein werden wir
jagkommandosoldaten dort mit dem
Fallschirm abspringen die Landezone
quasi zu sichern und danach werden wir
unseren Einsatz beginnen die
Österreicher in diesem Land zu
evakuieren also das Jagdkommando ist die
spezialeinsatzkraft des österreichischen
Bundesheers wir sind befähigt
Spezialeinsätze mit strategischenem
Ausmaß für das österreichische
Bundesheer im Innen und Ausland
durchzuführen wir sind mittels
Transportflugzeugen hier angelandet hier
das Szenario war das Flugfeld wurde von
Bandur
gesichert das sbandur ist einfach eine
zusätzliche Variante vom Bandur evoluion
die verlzten Zivilperson wurde hier von
der Ärztin der Herkules übernommen wird
weiter versorgt und nach Österreich
verbracht ein
Z man schaut dass man den Patienten
vorher isiert wie Intubation oder eben
ein zentraler Zugang und solche Sachen
damit man dann einfach wirklich in der
Luft keine bösen Überraschungen
[Musik]
erlebt im Rahmen einer
evakuierungsoperation ist es natürlich
wichtig die Österreicher die gefährdet
sind so schnell wie möglich zu
evakuieren ja in erster Linie probieren
wir jede Situation zu deeskalieren
und wir handeln nur unter Voraussetzung
nwer Hilfe und gehen jeden Konflikt aus
dem Weg
[Musik]
eigentlich oder wie jetzt letztlich
Erdbeben in der Türkei
ja natürlich sind wir da genauso gefragt
da war Kollege z.B von mir unten auch
ein Chirurg der hat dann letztendlich
den Patienten retten können indem er vor
Ort amputiert
[Musik]
hat
zurück in Österreich kann der verwundete
dann sofort in ein Krankenhaus gebracht
werden man hofft natürlich dass man
selbst so etwas nie braucht aber im
Ernstfall kann einem das das leeben
retten